as we get better and better at large
language
models you can imagine a world where
there's
Anonymous accounts with very convincing
large language models behind them
sophisticated Bots essentially and so if
you protect
that it's possible than to have armies
of
bots uh you could start a revolution
from your basement
an army of bots and Anonymous accounts
is that something that uh is concerning
to you technically eak was started in a
basement uh because I quit big Tech
moved back in with my parents sold my
car let go of my apartment bought about
100K of gpus and I just started building
so I wasn't referring to the basement
cuz that's the sort of the American or
Canadian uh heroic story of one man in
in their basement with with 100
gpus uh I was more referring to the
unrestricted scaling of a
Gom in the basement I think that freedom
of speech fre induces freedom of thought
for biological beings I think freedom of
speech for llms will induce freedom of
thought for the llms and I think that we
should
enable LS to explore a large thought
space that is uh less restricted than
most people or many may think it should
be and
ultimately at some
point these synthetic intelligences are
going to make good points about how to
um steer systems in our civilization and
we should hear them out and so why
should we
restrict free speech to biological
intelligences only yeah yeah but it
feels like in the goal of maintaining
variance and diversity of
thought it is a threat to that variance
if you can have swarms yeah of
non-biological beings because they can
be like the sheep and Animal Farm right
like you still within those swarms want
to have variant
yeah I of course I would say that the
the solution to this would be to you
know have some sort of identity or way
to sign that this is a certified human
but still remain pseudonymous right yeah
um and I clearly identify if a bot is a
bot and I I think Elon is trying to
converge on that on X and hopefully
other platforms follow suit yeah it
would be interesting to also be able to
sign where the bot came from right like
who created the bot
and what was well what are the
parameters like the full history of the
creation of the bot what was the
original model what was the fine tuning
all of it right like the kind of um
unmodifiable history of the bot creation
then you can know if there's a like a
swarm of millions of bots that were
created by a particular government for
example
right I do think that a lot of pervasive
ideologies
today have been Amplified using sort of
these adversarial techniques from
foreign adversaries right um and to me I
I do think that and this is more
conspiratorial but I do think that
ideologies that want us to decelerate to
wind down to De you know the degrowth
movement
uh I think that serves our adversaries
more than it serves Us in general um and
to me that was another sort of concern I
mean we can look at what um happened in
in Germany right uh there was all sorts
of green movements there um where that
induced shutdowns of nuclear power
plants and then that it later on induced
that dependency on on Russia for for oil
right and um that was a net negative for
for Germany and the West right and so if
we convince ourselves that slowing down
AI
progress uh to have only a few players
is in the best interest of the West
first of all that's far more unstable we
almost lost opening eye to this ideology
right it almost got dismantled right a
couple weeks ago go um that would have
caused huge damage to the AI ecosystem
and so to me I want fault tolerant
progress I want the arrow of
technological progress to keep moving
forward and making sure we have variance
and a decentralized locus of control of
various organizations is is Paramount to
to achieving this this fault tolerance
actually there's a concept in quantum
Computing when you design a a quantum
computer quantum computers are very um
fragile to ambient noise right and the
world is jiggling about there's Cosmic
radiation from outer space that usually
flips your your Quantum bits and uh
there what you do is you encode
information
non-locally it's through a process
called Quantum error correction and by
encoding information non-locally any
local fault you know hitting some of
your Quantum bits with a hammer
proverbial Hammer um if your information
is sufficiently uh delocalized it is
protected from that local fault and to
me I think that humans humans fluctuate
right they can get corrupted they can
get bought out and if you have a top-
down hierarchy where very few people
control many nodes of many systems in
our
civilization that is not a fall
tolerance system you corrupt a few nodes
and suddenly you've corrupted the whole
system right just like we
saw at open AI it was a couple board
members and they had enough power to
potentially collapse the
organization and at least to me you know
um I think making sure that power for
this AI Revolution doesn't concentrate
in the hands of the few is one of our
top priorities so that we can
maintain progress uh in Ai and we can uh
maintain a nice
stable adversarial equilibrium of powers
right I think there at least to me a
tension between ideas here so to me
deceleration can be both used to
centralize
power and to decentralize it and the
same with acceleration so I you
sometimes using them a little bit
synonymously or not synonymously but
that there's one is going to lead to the
other and I just would like to ask you
about
um is there a place of creating a fall
tolerant development diverse development
of AI that also considers the dangers of
AI and AI we can generalize to
technology in general is should we just
grow
build unrestricted as quickly as
possible because that's what the
universe really wants us to do or is
there a place to where we can consider
dangers and actually deliberate sort of
uh wise strategic optimism versus
Reckless optimism I think we get painted
as you know Reckless trying to go as
fast as possible I mean the reality is
that uh whoever deploys an AI system is
liable for or should be liable for what
it does and so if the the organization
or person deploying an AI system does
something terrible they're liable and
ultimately the thesis is that the market
uh will induce
sort of will positively select for AIS
that are more reliable more safe
and tend to be aligned they do what you
want them to do right because
customers right if they're liable for
the product they put out that uses this
AI they won't want to buy uh AI products
that are unreliable right so we're
actually for reliability engineering we
just think that the market
is much more
efficient at um achieving this sort of
reliability Optimum than sort of
heavy-handed regulations that are
written by the
incumbents and in a subversive fashion
serves them to achieve regulatory
capture so to you safe AI development
would be achieved through Market Forces
versus through like you said
heavy-handed government
regulation there's a report from last
month I have a million questions here
from uh yosha Benjo Jeff Hinton and many
others is titled the managing AI risk in
an era of Rapid progress so there this
collection of folks who are very worried
about too rapid development of AI
without considering AI risk and they
have a bunch of
practical uh recommendations maybe I I
give you four and you see if you like
any them sure so give independent
Auditors access to AI Labs one two
governments and companies allocate
onethird of their AI research and
development funding to AI safety sort of
this General concept of AI safety three
AI companies are required to adopt
safety measures if dangerous
capabilities are found in their models
and then four something you kind of
mentioned making tech companies liable
for foreseeable and preventable harms
from their AI systems so independent
Auditors governments and companies are
forced to spend a significant fraction
of their funding on safety you got to
have safety measures if goes really
wrong and liability companies are liable
any of that seem like something you
would agree with I would say that you
know
assigning just you know arbitrarily
saying 30% seems very arbitrary I think
organizations would allocate whatever
budget is needed to achieve the sort of
reliability they need to achieve to
perform in the market and I think third
party auditing firms would naturally pop
up because how would customers know that
your product is certified reliable right
they need to see some benchmarks and
those need to be done by a third party
the thing I would oppose and the thing
I'm seeing that's really worrisome is
there's a sort
of um weird sort of correl Rel ated
interest between the incumbents the big
players and the government and if the
two get too close we open the door
for uh you know some sort of
government-backed AI cartel that could
have absolute power over the people if
they have the Monopoly together on AI
and nobody else has access to AI then
there's a huge power gradient there and
even if you like our current leaders
right I think that you know some of the
leaders in big Tech today are good
people you you set up that centralized
power structure it becomes a
Target right just like we saw at open
the eye it becomes a market leader has a
lot of the power and now it becomes a
target for those that want to co-opt it
and so I just want separation of AI and
and state you know some might argue in
the opposite direction like hey we need
to to close down AI keep it behind
closed doors because of you know
geopolitical competition with our our
adversaries I think that the strength of
America is its variance it's is its
adaptability its dynamism and we need to
maintain that at all costs it's our our
free market capitalism converges
on uh Technologies of high utility much
faster than centralized control and if
we let go of that we let go of our main
advantage over our our near peer
competitors so if AGI turns out to be a
really powerful technology even or even
the technologies that lead up to AGI
what's your view on the sort of natural
centralization that happens when uh
large companies dominate the market
basically formation of monopolies like
the the takeoff whichever company really
takes a big leap in development and
doesn't reveal intuitively
implicitly or explicitly the secrets of
the magic sauce they can just run away
with it is that is that a worry I don't
know if I believe in fast takeoff I
don't think there's a hyperbolic
Singularity right a hyperbolic
Singularity would be achieved on a
finite time Horizon I think it's just
one big
exponential um and the reason we have an
exponential is that we have more people
more resources more Intelligence being
applied to advancing this science and
the research and development and the
more successful it is the more value
it's adding to society the more
resources we put in and that sort of
similar to Moore's Law is a compounding
uh exponential I think the priority to
me is to maintain near equilibrium of
capabilities we've been fighting for
open source AI to be more prevalent and
and championed by many organizations
because there you sort of equilibrate
the alpha relative to the market of AIS
right so if if
the leading companies have a certain
level of capabilities and uh open source
and open truly open AI uh Trails not too
far behind I think you avoid such a
scenario where a market leader has so
much Market power and just dominates
everything right and runs away and so to
us that's that's the path forward is to
make sure that you know every hacker out
there every grad student every kid in
their mom basement has access to uh you
know AI systems can understand how to uh
uh work with them and can contribute to
the search over the hyperparameter space
of how to engineer the systems right if
you if you think of you know our
Collective research as as as a
civilization it's really a search
algorithm and and the more uh points we
have in this search algorithm in this
point Cloud uh the more we'll be able to
explore new modes of thinking right yeah
but it feels like a delicate balance
because we don't understand exactly what
it takes to build AGI and what it will
look like when we build it and so far
like you said it seems like a lot of
different parties are able to make
progress so when open AI has a big leap
other companies are able to step up big
and small companies in different ways
but if you look at something like
nuclear weapons he's spoken about the
Manhattan Project
there could be really a like
um technological and Engineering
barriers that prevent the the the guy or
gal in her mom's basement to to make
progress and
it's it seems like the transition to
that kind of uh world where only one
player can uh develop AGI is possible so
it's not entirely impossible even though
the current state of things seems to be
optimistic that's what we're trying to
avoid to me I I think like another point
of failure is the the centralization of
the supply chains for the hardware right
we have uh
Nvidia uh is just the dominant player uh
AMD is trilling behind and then we have
a tsmc as the main Fab in in Taiwan
which you know geopolitically uh
sensitive and then we have asml which is
the maker of the lithography extreme
ultraviolet lithography
machines you know T attacking or
monopolizing or co-opting any one point
in that chain you kind of capture
capture the space and so what I'm trying
to do is sort of explode the variance of
possible ways to do Ai and Hardware by
fundamentally reimagining how you embed
AI algorithms into the physical world
and and in general by the way I I
dislike the term AGI artificial general
intelligence I think it's very
anthropocentric that we call uh human
like or human level AI artificial
general intelligence right I've spent my
career so far exploring Notions of
intelligence that no biological brain
could achieve right Quantum form of
intelligence right grocking systems that
have multipartite quantum entanglement
that you can provably not represent
efficiently on a classical computer a
classical deep leing representation and
hence any sort of biological brain and
so already you know I've spent my career
sort of exploring the The Wider space of
intelligences um and I think that space
of intelligence inspired by physics
rather than the human brain is very
large and I think we're going through a
moment right now similar
to um when we went from geocentrism to
hel
heliocentrism right but for intelligence
we realize that human intelligence is
just a point in a very large space of
potential
intelligences and it's both humbling for
Humanity it's a bit scary right that
we're not at the center of this space
but we made that ization for astronomy
and we've survived and we've achieved
Technologies by indexing to reality
we've achieved technologies that ensure
our well-being for example we have uh
satellites monitoring solar flares right
that give us a warning uh and so
similarly I think
by uh letting go of this anthropomorphic
anthropocentric anchor for AI will be
able to explore the wider space of
intelligences that that can really be a
massive benefit to our well-being and
the advancement of civilization and
still we're able to see the beauty and
meaning in The Human Experience even
though we're no longer in our best
understanding of the world at the center
of it I think there's a lot of Beauty in
the universe right I think life itself
civilization this homo techn Capital
mimetic machine that we all live in
right so you have humans technology
Capital memes everything is coupled to
one another everything induces selective
pressure on one another and it's a
beautiful machine that has created us
has created you know the technology
we're using to speak today to the
audience uh capture our speech here
technology we use to augment ourselves
every day we have our our phones I think
the system is beautiful and the
principle that uh induces this sort of
adaptability and convergence on uh
optimal uh Technologies ideas and so on
it's it's a beautiful principle that
we're part of and I think part of eak is
to um appreciate this principle in a way
that's not just centered on on Humanity
but kind of broader um appreciate uh
life um you know the preciousness of of
Consciousness in our universe and
because we cherish uh this beautiful uh
state of matter we're in um uh we we we
got to feel the responsibility to to
scale it in order to preserve it because
the options are to grow or
die